many sounds means something the danger
one is this green chip is the louder one
and then the whistle one is the food one
and each each sound have some different
things but it took me a while to get
used to it
[Music]
what are the things you remember from
your childhood
I remember a Countryside with spring
onions all over the place
and plenty vegetables
I just don't remember very much about my
parents or nothing else
I am I remember somebody came from
behind and blocked my face with a cloth
and I just thought to see her black
hands you know just really strong
personality person who squeezed my face
and I just felt very very wilted this
smell was very very strong smell
and I just my body didn't
cope with a strength I just couldn't
fight
I was just taken away you know I
remember seeing some children behind me
crying
so what happened to you after that
abduction
I think I was a long drive it was just
driving him really
feels like it must have been a bumpy
road it's not very stable
and um
I think I must have fell asleep or
something in between
I wonder it's a long time
and then it was dark
and in the dark I noticed some men carry
me or too many carry me and
felt some
Woodlands a lot of plants I could feel
the batching my you know
to my arms
and then they dropped me so quickly they
just really and the rush did drop me
there
and I've just
felt so tired I just when I
saw them going I just didn't want them
to leave me I was worried about it I saw
their legs when I was a black one and it
was a white man moving away in shorts
and I just wanted to beg them to come
back for me not to leave me there
I kept very
hoping that somebody might come back for
me it never happened
and it was very horrible time and
didn't know where to go
until the daytime came in the morning
and then I sat and cry and I just didn't
do very much I was really confused
nowhere to go
until soon I don't know how long was it
but I heard a screech noise in the tree
and it was um one of the monkeys
just one and then I came down one of
them and then they always follow him and
then the one came first he staring at me
and it keeps testing with the finger
it's really quite strong little monkey
which really you know I keep poking on
me and I just didn't want to bother I
just didn't want to move I just didn't
want to do anything until some more came
and I felt a little bit better
I just that is a nice feeling about to
see something and the moment I just
forgot to cry and I still was writing
about it
they were so do
um a very pale from the skin on their
eyes were really round
and the face which
bright like a bay well a cream Brown
pale brown color
and they were really fast they're very
speedy I just remember that the little
eye it's just very rounded eyes and it's
squeaking noise they keep looking at and
staring
and then they go bored with me I don't
think I wanted to do anything it just
went
and they keep coming back they keep
going and coming back I did try to get
closer to them they didn't push me away
well I mean I've done a few weeks or
months and no idea but they are finally
they accept me and I felt
like I was part of them that this group
and I just began to climb trees with
them
and I did became quite good eventually
I'm managed to climb tree with great
difficulties
and I just sat with them at the top they
never pushed me away
and we just sometimes they used to come
and pick things in my ears behind my
ears or they're just looking for things
on me to eat after a while they became
used to me
and suddenly one of them landed to my
shoulders believe me that was fantastic
because when you are so late for for
days or weeks it's just a nice feeling
on my shoulders as a comfort
it was for me
I mean I just began to forget who is
coming for me I just didn't bother
anymore about it
because they began to come moral more
often and I was more included and for me
that was a very Comfort moment
what did you eat and drink
plenty water and leaves but to be honest
I was feeling hungry I was beginning to
feel quite
fancy something to eat but I didn't know
what to eat
except the water and that
I know this the monkeys used to
eat things they keep eating something
and I keep watching where they get in
this food and I just took me days to
find out where they're getting the food
except the one of them was a very good
one
he used to go when the some Indian
people used to fall asleep and they used
to hear the sound the people falling
asleep and he went in in the room very
quiet and he grew a lot of food out of
this room with huge amounts of fruits
and it used to carry so much that he
dropped and that was the first time I
came out and found a banana or other
things and I picked it up quickly but
you better move because if you don't
they take it away quickly so I learned
to eat as fast as I could always they
used to eat berries and things
and some of them were very really
delicious but some of them were really
very very acid not very nice but you get
to know the the berries
eventually I became familiar with them
how they were getting I'd have to learn
to recognize the sounds
so you've learned to recognize the
sounds they would make it back to them
and it took me a while but each time I
mean this creature one you have to
really be careful you have to hide away
many sounds means something the danger
one is this green chip is the louder one
and then the whistle one is the food one
and each each sound have some different
things but it took me a while to get
used to it I just learned from watching
the way doing when every time I hear
this sound did you ever had any issues
because of the of the fruits you ate or
anything you ate that was poisonous or
anything like that I did eventually
after a while it was quite a bit a long
time when I found a tree we had a little
velvety Browns nice you know like a
broad Bean like
and it had a sticky fruit inside and it
was very delicious I just keep eating
and eating and eating I was hungry
and then but no not them seems to be
interested not that the monkeys took it
away so I had had my share
until hours later
um I noticed my stomach I was feeling
really dizzy very unwell
and I was just looking at
other grandpa monkey you know it was
just nobody else to go to but I was just
crying my eyes out because the pain was
really excruciated
until he just walked towards me and I
wasn't sure what he's going to do
and then he came close up and then he
pushed me like he was crossed with me
and I became afraid
I had no idea what he was going to do
but he put me into a pun of Watertown
when she was not very pleasant he just
feels forcing me again
and they're like
I think I had my strength and I just
jump out and I was just feeling very
sick and I vomit and I vomit
until I look at his face and I just felt
his something about his eyes he didn't
want to do me harm he just stand there
look at me in peace and he's staring at
me like
I didn't
didn't feel frightened anymore
I felt something he's trying to do with
me and I didn't understood Sam
after I felt sick
I felt better
and I just you know
that I thought he was going to take me
back into he didn't he just let me there
and then it just went away
anaj
understood that moment I never forget
whilst you were in the jungle have you
ever seen any people
yes sometimes we used to see some people
stealing animals and it was terrifying I
was just looking behind the branches
inside this tree I decided not to come
out I didn't fancy
come out there because I thought they're
going to put me into the sack with the
animals I just didn't fancy doing that
and I never came out I never let anybody
see me I used to see a black soldier
occasionally with the black gun and
black Wellies or boots or something
and he was standing in front of the tree
and I had he didn't realize I was behind
there because I thought he was one of
the people who went to put me into the
soccer field come out
eventually he went but to me that was a
fear
about that particular
man it was like a
a uniform or something
how did you leave the jungle what
happened why
I never thought I was going to leave it
until eventually one day I wish a man
came
um I guess he was about 40 something
which he must have been 20 year old
young girl
and I would just she was really looked
very kind and slightly smiled and that
attracts me from the Micron I just look
at her and I thought oh I just felt to
go towards her I just feel attracted
that she was nice and my you know my
feeling my instant
I walked towards her because I thought
she's nice
and then the man grabbed me and he was a
rough man he just took me quickly and
put me into the it was like a I don't
know a truck with animals inside
I began to feel really fearful about
to get into that truck I just wish I
went to go back to the Jungle I had
intention of getting out and go back
into the jungle I just went to go with
this person because he wasn't very nice
I know it's feeling a bit bright and and
then I saw a monkey in a box
and I was trying to trying to talk
I'm trying to communicate with them and
try and put a little hole I opened a
hole in a box and he told me off not
recorded that box and I'll just keep
looking at this monkey through the box
where where did they take you and they
carry on driving and driving it was a
long drive and I was maybe it must have
been afternoon and then it goes night
and it was a lot of flashy lights which
I was terrifying to see these flashy
lights
and it was a street with cask
and I never see that before well maybe
I've been too long inside and I just
didn't realize about traffic illness and
so I became quite scared until they stop
the car
and he pulled me out with his work with
this anger and I just felt really I
thought he was going to
know what to think about which is really
bright and I'm just looking for the
jungle but it was too late it was a road
with traffic
and they knocked at the door at
somebody's door and they went and opened
the door
and it rubbed me inside and he just took
me to this
it was a lady who came out with green
eyes
and long hair and then to a tall lady
and then she give you some I don't know
I think it was money okay basically give
you something on his hands
and he the next minute I noticed these
people left me with this woman it looks
very ruthless
and she had a whip in her hands
and nudge he just turned off with with a
young girl
and they disappear and they left me and
I was feeling very
very insecure
because I just didn't want to be left in
there
this woman
she used to beat me with this weep which
is really painful it's a whipped cheese
to cut in the waist and choose to whip
me with that and I just didn't there to
disobey her there were some neighbors
children's they're trying to teach me
how to talk and how to I just how to be
like a child which I couldn't because
they they spot my problems I wasn't a
normal like them so you went to the
jungle at around four years old and how
old do you think you were at this point
[Music]
I had no idea of moons have been eight
or nine
kind of thing feels like
I didn't want to
carry on living in there because I began
to learn about the young young girls in
this place and men used to come and take
them on something I began I think it was
a brussel house and it was a man came
one day and he said where is she and
then she said give me some crisps or you
give a package of Crispies she will come
to it and I didn't I'll hide under the
bed in the entrance in a sitting room I
saw them coming
and they left the door open so I came
out under the bed and I ran as fast as I
could no shoes or anything I just ran as
fast as I could
and I left them looking for me
I am
I was very good at stealing Foods in a
restaurant they used to put the plate
sausages or something on the top of the
counter and I used to pass by and get it
and run faster with it I used to have
the way to climb up the tree quickly and
nobody the police never looked in the
trees they just never look at the top of
the trees but I was sure they're not
going to catch me the lady next door the
granny she understood what was I'm going
through I think she felt I was in a
great dangerous place she heard me when
I used to be beaten on something
she was very concerned about a good
field she wanted to care for me
and I felt
I never trust anybody but when she was
looking at me I felt for the first time
I could trust
a
human
foreign
told me that I should
go with her and I will be all right
and I went to meet this old lady in the
park she said she was going to meet me
there at one o'clock
any Saturday
and she took me with her and then she
sent me to her friend she wanted to send
me to her daughter and Bogota
and she sent me alone in a plane and she
bought me a beautiful dress for me and
she said like I just had difficulty
wearing clothes because I wasn't used to
wear clothes in the forest and for me to
wear these things are very uncomfortable
shoes but she trained me to use these
shoes and to work properly you know like
ape and I got very offensive about it
[Laughter]
and she said give me a picture of her
daughter to find her in the Apple
and I did
found her daughter and it was great
moment when a lady collect me
she brought me to um
to her home
when that woman in Bogota who became
your family when she saved you and you
became part of her family how
how did she help you to get to the UK it
was her sister with Sam a very rich
people and they our student I became a
nanny
uh in this family I think many children
enjoy my company because children are
like a monkeys and we have something to
connect
this is really good
they still invite me today children's
weddings and they include me like a
family
and it's related to this lady who adopts
me
nowadays have you ever
tried or have you ever thought about
going back to the Jungle or finding the
jungle wave yes
I did
I saved some money I had a job and I
saved some money because it's always
been in my mind I've been asking people
some professionals how the monkey lives
and they told me they leave 50 years
I saved some money and I went and caught
I called the float as a coach in
Colombia called flood or something
and they take you to many places so I
found out what a work jungle because I
had no idea this is unfortunately I
can't remember which jungle I came from
I just hoping that any jungle that where
the monkeys are because I was pretty
sure as soon as they see me they're
going to recognize me and I just felt
like a lost family
and I was desperate to go to see them I
just felt I reconna I think I recognized
the area if you see the jungle
I think I will recognize because I got
the you know in my mind what it looks
like and I never saw the monkeys and I
was really frustrated that was the only
time I did
I thought I was going to find it never
happened
when you look back at your life and at
the time you spat in the jungle how do
you feel about that period I um I felt
to go back sometimes in my roof times
I I did regret it coming out
but I don't know I'm unsettled in the
city I'm getting comfortable I had my
two daughters
and that's my family
today
is the best thing that happened to me
I learned how to love people from them
I really
I'm so special for me moment
[Music]
whilst everybody was having their orgies
free love sex they would no longer be
permitted to enjoy the sex for each
other they had to fantasize that they
were actually having sex with Jesus
um men included